hey guys welcome to the channel my name
is clinton jones i am the punisher
and i'm here to teach you guys how to
turn yourself into a photorealistic
robot using visual effects this
is a whopper of a tutorial it's
basically a mini
master class on how to shoot your
footage
track that footage bring that 3d track
into cinema 4d
create your own custom hdri get a robot
we're going to learn how to texture this
robot to make it look
photo real it really comes down to the
textures i actually got 50
off my surface imperfection pack for
this week and this week
only from there we're going to slap on a
rococo mocap suit
record some custom animation then we'll
wrap things up by talking about
render settings we'll export it and
composite in after effects
i promise you guys are going to learn a
ton about vfx
by the end of this thing and if you guys
are new to this channel it's all about
learning and growing together in our
creative passions
so it's time to dive in and turn
yourself into a robot
starting with shooting your footage
so one thing i'm going for and trying to
keep in mind when i'm shooting my
footage is two things
one is visual contrast the patterns here
in this brick work is perfect on the
ground
there's little leaves and stuff that the
auto tracker can catch on to and there's
also the background here
all these leaves and different points on
the wall the program is gonna have a
better time tracking it if there's more
visual contrast for it to latch onto
and the second thing i'm trying to watch
out for is my shutter speed if it's
motion blur city and your camera is
moving really fast
it makes it very difficult to latch on
to those points of visual contrast so
you want to crank your shutter speed
so that your motion blur is reduced so
that you can track it easier
in post okay so if you guys can you'll
want to shoot
a custom high dynamic range image of
your set where you're shooting your
footage
i'm doing this with a 360 camera this is
the insta360 one
r the theory behind custom hdris is that
you can
light your actual 3d models in your 3d
program
with an image of your actual set where
you shot your footage
this works by combining a number of
bracketed images together
in order to create one high dynamic
range image
so if you guys are gonna do this which
you should be if you're trying to get
your render as nice and photo realistic
as possible
i have a separate tutorial which you can
check out right here
where i break down the very specifics of
this process
so now that you guys have your footage
we need to 3d track this
meaning we're going to create a virtual
camera copy
of your camera movement on set and for
that i'm going to be using the most
accessible software i know
after effects all right let's do this
let's select our footage go up to effect
come on down here to perspective and 3d
camera tracker is exactly what you want
now
by default it's just going to start
doing its thing up here in the top left
you can see it's initializing but let me
go through these settings while this
thing actually does its magic
so the shot type fixed angle of view
that means that we didn't do any rack
zooms or anything
if you guys are zooming in and out
you're going to want to change that to
variable zoom
now the horizontal angle of view if we
get some jankiness on our track and we
want to try and like
spice it up just a bit what you can do
is set to specify angle of view
which is different than focal length so
i've provided a link to a chart
in the description that allows you to
look up your camera's focal length and
gives you the horizontal angle of view
our track is done we can select the
effect to make sure that the points are
visible and if not hit ctrl shift h
and that'll actually show any of the the
ui stuff that we can't see
if these points are too small for you
you can change the track point size up
to like 300 or so
just to make it a little bit easier to
see and then finally if we drop down
this advanced tab
and your track still isn't working you
can check this detailed analysis box and
i don't know it's just the do a better
job box
that should just be there all the time i
don't know why it's not so if i scrub
through the footage you can see that
most of these points here are down on
this brick that's the area with the
visual noise i was talking about the
visual contrast
that the program would really latch onto
and if we scale up these tracker points
you can see that there's a lot on the
back
wall as well now what we need to do is
determine where we are in 3d space right
now the camera doesn't know that this is
the floor
or this is the back wall so let's go
ahead and give it a little bit of
information to work with so with the
camera tracker effect selected let's
just make
a big selection here clicking and
dragging i'm going to right click
and you see this option set ground plane
in origin let's go ahead and click that
because that's going to tell
the program that these points we've
selected are the ground plane
and the center of them is the origin so
we'll click that we'll right click again
and we'll make
a solid and a camera and what that's
going to do is basically place a solid
right here on the ground
with a 3d camera and you know when we
move around the scene we can see that
that solid is perfectly stuck to the
ground
now i do want to orient this a little
bit so i'm going to hit r
and then we're just going to rotate this
around until it lines up generally with
the patterns
on the brick there and maybe we want to
put a plane on the back wall there just
to represent that wall
in 3d space so select all these points
on the back wall right click
create a solid and there you go you have
a solid on the back wall
representing that space in 3d
but what we're really looking for is
that our ground plane doesn't slide all
over the ground
you want it locked to that ground
surface and if you guys have made it
this far
then we're good to go and ready to move
on to normalizing our scene
and what i mean by normalizing if we
were to bring this 3d scene into cinema
4d
cinema wouldn't really know the scale of
the scene it wouldn't know how it's
rotated or oriented so what we need to
do is
normalize this thing and i'm going to go
back into after effects and use a
free script called normalize it's made
by a guy named action movie dad who has
a lot of fun with his kids doing vfx
it's a very handy script that all of you
guys should have because
it's free and it'll save you a ton of
time so let's use this script to prepare
our 3d scene in after effects for cinema
4d or blender maya 3ds max whatever you
guys are using
so what we're going to do is name our
ground plane as ground so if i go to
file
script and i run normalize right all i
have to do is select the ground
and the track and hit this first button
right here normalize track
bam and that's going to do a bunch of
stuff on the back end but basically if i
make a new solid
and i make it a 3d layer it's going to
spawn that 3d layer right at the origin
point
and it's going to totally be lined up
and super easy and accessible for us to
drop in 3d assets not only in after
effects
but when we re-export this to c4d it's
gonna be a lot more
normal it's gonna be normalized so let's
go file
export max on cinema 4d exporter we'll
hit okay
and now when i drop in a figure it's
much more accurate
we still need to adjust the scale a
little bit but the center point from
after effects is now aligned with the
origin in cinema 4d
you've normalized your 3d scene you got
past the technical jargon
this was such a hurdle for me going from
2d to 3d it took me years to figure out
now we're almost there we're almost to
the fun stuff we just need to export a
jpeg sequence so that we can see our
footage in our 3d program of choice
so just hit ctrl shift forward slash
change it to a jpeg sequence
and make sure you guys save it in the
correct output go ahead and hit render
back in c4d let's go ahead and double
click in the materials window down here
open this thing up and in the texture
channel for color
let's just go ahead and load our jpeg
sequence by double clicking the first
image now by default this thing doesn't
play we need to tell c4d
how many frames it has so click this
little icon here let's go to animation
and calculate
if your numbers are all astronomical
then you can basically hit control
k inside of after effects and that'll
bring up your composition
settings just make sure your start frame
is set to zero the last thing we'll need
to do to make sure this thing's
animating in our viewport is go to the
viewport option and click
animate preview now from here we can
hold down this floor button
make a background and drop that material
onto the background
and scrub through our footage we can see
that this character is sticking to the
floor
but we notice that the character is a
little too small
so what we actually need to do here is
go to this tracking folder
and by default it's in a null object in
order to do this correctly we need to
put it inside of another null object so
hit alt
g to put that in a null but if we start
scaling this thing all over the place
it's not going to scale from the zero
point that's because our gizmo is you
know
in some random direction what we need to
do is get that gizmo to the zero
zero origin point so to control the
gizmo we just hit
l or click this little button over here
the axis tool
and down at the bottom here we just need
to zero out our position values
and then when we hop into the camera and
start scaling our scene
you can see that it's scaling properly
we're not scaling up
the figure we're scaling up the scene
and the proper way to scale this
if you just click and drag it will not
work so we need to actually type these
numbers in
to the coordinates down here so if i
just hit uh
you know 0.5 across the board it's going
to look proper
one thing i'll actually do is stand in
my footage to make sure that i'm getting
the right scale but in this case i think
we can just eye this up and that feels
about right
and the last thing we should do here is
rotate our scene by 90 degrees
alright guys so now it's time to match
the lighting so whether you're using a
custom hdri or an hdri from hdri haven
we need to take that high dynamic range
image and match it
to the footage all right so i know i
mentioned i have that custom hdri
tutorial but for those of you guys who
want to stay put
i'm just going to do a really quick
breakdown of generally what's going on
with that
so in photoshop i have all of these
bracketed images that i took
on my insta360 1r i'm going to go to
file
automate merge to hdr pro i'm just going
to add all the open files and hit ok
and this new window pops up combining
all of these different images together
into one
32-bit image let's go ahead and open
that up
and we'll adjust the exposure to our
liking and we'll save it as a radiance
file.hdr that's what we want all 32 bits
now in my case i'm using octane but if
you guys are using redshift or arnold
that's totally fine too
again if you're in blender we just need
to make sure that we're in our render
view
so as soon as you guys hit render you
can see your object and the world around
it right now it's all white because we
don't have an hdri let's go ahead and
change that
so i'm going to go to objects hdri
environment
and i'm going to go ahead and load that
custom hdri that we created
boom and by default we're actually
seeing this hdri in the background here
we want to switch over to path tracing
and if you guys aren't seeing the
background just make sure you go up to
the octane settings window here
and you know we can even some of these
settings out gi clamp set to one
but really it's the alpha channel we're
gonna make sure you check alpha channel
and uncheck keep environment that way
we're able to see our footage
instead of the hdri layer but i want to
show you guys this cool trick
go ahead and make a sphere and we're
going to try and match our hdri image
to our footage let's create an octane
glossy material
change the index to one that way we get
a chrome ball
and we'll apply it to the sphere here
and now we're really set up to judge
the lighting of the scene the hdri is
more saturated
it's a little bit more contrasty too
let's composite this
hdri image in the node editor so i'm
going to click this
environment tag and right down here you
can see this node button
so let's go ahead and scroll down and
find the color correction node and we'll
drop it right in the middle there
the first thing i'm going to do is drop
the gamma down so it washes out the
image a little bit and i'm going to take
it down a little bit further
and the saturation certainly needs to
come down so we'll take that down to 0.8
as well
that's not far off maybe we can take the
brightness to 1.2
and this feels a lot better to me now
here's a pro tip these white
areas here in the hdri are blown out
compared to our footage so if you give
this camera an octane camera tag
and we go into the camera imager
settings enable it you can actually
crank up the highlight compression
to save some of those highlights
and the last thing to check here is that
your hdri image is
oriented properly so uh in the footage
right we can see that we're facing this
back wall here
and when i go to direct lighting it
switches to the hdri
it's facing the back wall so that way we
know our scene is oriented properly the
light is coming from the correct
direction
finally let's go ahead and add a plane
hit t we can scale it up
and let's make an octane diffuse
material we'll drop that onto the plane
double click it we'll go to the common
tab and check shadow catcher
what that does is basically hide the
plane but keep the shadows
and that's very important for
compositing anything into your
live action footage is keeping those
shadows that's what grounds it to your
scene
i'm really excited for you guys making
it this far because whatever you drop
into your scene at this point is going
to be perfectly composited it's going to
be
lit and it's going to be tracked into
your scene
so now let's throw in some robots it's
about time huh
so i briefly want to go over three
different methods
to sourcing a robot starting with
building one yourself
so you guys know peter france if not
even living in a hole somewhere
this dude is incredible he's a blender
whiz kid and he's kid bashing a robot
with a bunch
of photo scan pieces that he took from
his phone this is all just for free
he's doing it in blender he's using free
software to photos getting his stuff
and he connected it to mocap data that
he shot with his rococo suit
and made something really sick so
another way of doing it is actually to
kit bash it with pre-existing
models online like batali bulgarov stuff
this guy is
insane and he has a ton of different
packs that you guys can go through
to build to your heart's content or you
can just buy a model of a robot
cg trader is my favorite place to go for
stuff like this it's very inexpensive
and the quality is through the roof
mookie has some seriously high detailed
gundams
that are going to be perfect for exactly
what we're going to do so i'm going to
buy this bring it into c4d
and start building this thing out so i
know we need to optimize this model we
just got
and animate it but i want to jump right
to texturing because that is honestly
the best part for me specifically
the surface imperfections getting it all
scratched and nasty and weathered down
and i actually have a pack of 16-bit
seamless surface imperfections
for you guys to use i'm running a 50 off
deal on it for this
week only there's a link in the
description but if you guys want to
learn how to create your
own surface imperfections i got another
video breaking down
the entire process every little detail
all right guys let's jump into texturing
so we're talking
like water drops on the top we got
leakage on the side we got scratches on
the edges we got dirt
in the corners and that's all broken up
very specifically so it's not uniform
across the whole thing we also
are breaking up the reflection in a very
specific way
with some surface imperfections and you
got scratches all over the top of this
thing
once we build out this master material
in three little chunks
then all you have to do is duplicate
this material and change the colors
and then you got your fully textured
robot so let's jump into this
all right i'm gonna break down this base
coat for you it's in four little chunks
as you guys can see right here
very simple very straightforward so i'm
gonna just note this
up front every time i bring in an image
texture it's attached to a texture
projection node
with the projection set the box and a
transform node so we can scale this
you know all these different textures up
and down all right so here we go four
simple little steps starting with
the roughness if i were to just take all
this stuff off we can see that we're
starting with
a base octane glossy material set to a
blue color
if i just take this first piece and pipe
it in it's simply a
like fingerprint smudge texture it's
being combined
with this other one this is like a shoe
print kind of a texture
i'm using a mix node and i'm using an
octane gradient to just kind of control
the intensity of all that
now we come down to the bump alright so
we're doing this again
in two separate chunks that are being
mixed together
the first chunk is an octane noise this
is a very specific case where the
texture projection is set to xyz to uvw
and i'm taking down the intensity of
this octane noise that you see here
with a multiply node and a float texture
that's set to 0.1
if i were to set this to 1 that's what
it would look like by default that noise
right there
but we want to take it down so it
doesn't break up our reflections too
much
that's part one and the final part right
here is
basically the same thing but instead of
noise it's another
image texture and this time it is just
like a scratch
texture and we're digging these
scratches into the base material here
we're combining these two together with
an ad and piping that into the bump
and that is our base coat
moving on to part two this is the
scratches we got scratches on the edges
of
all of these pieces here as well as some
scratches on the surface
now in order to see through these
scratches to see through our base paint
and get to a material underneath you
need that material underneath
and it is a very simple octane metal
material
with a roughness turned up it's very
simple
very straightforward now we're combining
our base coat
with that octane metal with a mix
material all right so you have your slot
material one
material two and the amount is going to
be a specific little setup that i'm
going to break down for you guys right
now
so once again we're going to break this
up into two parts part one
and part two we're combining them both
to get this final effect
it all comes down to this dirt node this
dirt node is basically going to focus on
either the edges
or the corners and i'm going to check
this invert normal box to make sure it's
focused on the corners
now this is about half the work all
right we have this thing focused
with the small radius and high strength
on just the corners
of our robot and it's uniform across the
whole thing
but to keep it realistic i want to break
up
these edges here with some more surface
imperfections
so so here's a scratch texture that's
you know slapped over top everything
and it's combined with a multiply node
to this
other scratch texture you know it's just
giving it a bunch of bunch of scratches
basically over the top of this thing
but obviously i don't want it this
scratch that looks kind of janky
so i'm using a add node to
basically blend between this dirt node
and the multiply
and that gets you this effect right here
it's just chipping away on the corners
here
it's pretty uniform and you can use this
transform node to scale these things up
scale them down do whatever you want get
the look you're going for
but i'm feeling this right here i think
it looks pretty sweet so on top of this
we gotta have some scratches on the
actual faces of this thing too so i'm
using another surface imperfection here
from my pack
to get some lighter scratches across the
top of this thing
i'm combining step one and step two with
a multiply node
to get you the best of both worlds you
got scratches on the edges
as well as the scratches on top of all
these surfaces here
and finally let's talk about the dirt we
have dirt buildup in the corners
we have leaky water streaks here down
the side
we have water spots on the top and a
general
kind of wiped dirt across the entire
robot
so let's go ahead and break this down
once again
this is split up into four very
simple steps each one of these steps are
combined together in twos
and then those twos are combined into
the all four of them together
to get the amount for this mixed
material
now just like our scratches we needed
that chrome to to basically see through
to and for our dirt we just need a dirt
texture so this is an octane diffused
material set to a tan color
mixing between the scratch mix material
and this octane dirt all right so let's
break it down nice and simple
step by step here technically this
should be step one this is step two all
right so just like our scratches we're
using this dirt node
we're unchecking this box so it's
hitting the crevices as opposed to the
edges
and we wanna break this up it's too
uniform for us right
so we're actually going to use an octane
noise node again when it's noise
we're just setting the projection to xyz
to uvw as opposed to box
and that's going to give us you know
this kind of look right here
that we can definitely change the
contrast on go to 100
and we're combining that dirt node with
that noise node
with an add node to get this kind of
look right here but let's go and let's
go and take that
contrast back down to one like we had it
so it's breaking it up just a little bit
so that's part one part two gets us our
dirt wipes on top just like our
scratches
we still wanna have some dirt across the
top of this thing so i'm using another
surface imperfection from my pack to
just get some wiped dirt across this
and both of those are being combined
with a multiply node
to get you the best of both worlds dirt
in the corners
and dirt on top now we're not done we
gotta talk about those water streaks
so step three and four are basically the
same thing
just with a different image texture so
let me let me show you guys how this
works
so i'm using a falloff node to really
focus on
faces that are pointing towards the sky
or
faces that are just pointing towards the
ground in this case it's just the sky
right
so that's the falloff node set to normal
versus
vector 90 degrees it's a really cool one
i like it a lot
now this image texture that i'm using
this is just like a water spots texture
from my pack as well
and it's getting you this nice kind of
stained water effect going here
i'm combining both of these together
with an add node
all right so that gets you just these
water spots
on the top marked by that falloff node
the gradient node here
is just in between this image texture in
the ad
and that's just you know i'm just
crunching this up to get a little bit
more juice
out of that imperfection now lastly the
final step
i'm duplicating this whole setup control
dragging it down
to get this right here i switched out
the image texture
for more of a streaky kind of
imperfection and for the fall off i'm
just
inverting these values all right so
instead of on top
we flip those and now it's everywhere
except
the top i'm combining them with an add
all right because we just copied it from
here
and now both step three and four are
combined with a multiply node
that's going to give you this dirty
streaky water look
and finally to wrap it all out we're
just using another multiply node
to combine these multiply nodes to get
you all
four dirt textures to finish out
this master material we got the corner
dirt we got the wipes we got the streaks
we got the water spots
from this angle you're actually able to
see the scratches a little bit better on
the surface as well as the scratches
on the corners you can go to town on
this you can max it out
but i think this is pretty sweet so all
you need to do here
is duplicate your master material this
one mix material right here
and start changing out the colors in
your base metal
and that way we can color our model to
get a photorealistic
robot
so at this point we need to optimize our
model
and get it ready to animate for those of
you who are still with me i want to say
thank you so much
and ask you guys to leave a comment down
below on what other topics you want me
to really deep dive into
let's jump in in order to get this robot
hooked up to some awesome mocap data we
need to break up the robot
into a number of pieces here very
similar to
the structure of the mocap data you know
we want to break the robot
up into shoulder arm forearm hand it's
all listed out here head neck torso and
hips
the thigh the shin and the foot that way
all that stuff can be dropped in
to these different bones here and
basically be parented to all of the
different layers
making it look like it's moving
correctly so most of us downloading
models
are not lucky enough to have the model
broken up in very specific ways like
this
so how are we going to do that so by
default this gundam comes as
one piece it all moves together we want
to get it separated into its
individual parts like you guys just saw
now the best way to do that that i've
come across
is to go into object mode and use the
loop select tool that's going to be ul
on the shortcut and you're going to want
to select
just the shoulder for instance here and
i'm holding shift to select different
parts of this thing
and if i hit the shortcut u y that's
going to be grow selection
and i'm just going to mash that until it
basically selects
all of the polygons on the object that i
have selected the gross selection tool
basically works
like a disease that just spreads across
all the different faces of this
model this is a tedious process but it
needs to be done in order to break these
pieces up
to have full control over the animation
of our robot so i'll move these polygons
away from the robot just to make sure i
have everything selected
i'll undo that and then we're going to
hit the shortcut u p
to disconnect these objects from the
main robot piece you can see that it
made
a new object and if we go back to the
gundam the original one we can actually
delete those polygons
and now if we solo this shoulder we just
have this shoulder piece
you know we can name that right shoulder
and we'll continue doing this operation
for all the rest of the limbs
until we have everything broken up into
all its individual pieces
once they're separated we can t pose our
robot overlay it
on top of these bones here and then have
them be parented to the motion tracking
data so that it copies the exact
movements that you made when you were in
your mocap suit
your robot is ready for animation so
let's talk about some motion capture
data
now we're going to be using a rococo
mocap suit to get some custom mocap data
but i want to fill you guys in on a
really cool motion capture resource
it's a website called miximo it's paired
with your adobe login so if you guys
have one
you can use this site and it offers you
a bunch of different motion capture data
anything from jumping flying
dancing dying literally anything you can
think of you guys can find it on miximo
this isn't a sponsor it's just a
fantastic resource that you guys gotta
know about
if you don't already know about it so if
you guys don't have either a rococo
or xn's motion capture suit they can be
a bit pricey miximo is
the way to go but i'm going to be using
a rococo motion capture suit
now this is basically the same way we
did bosstown dynamics we used an
xsense motion capture suit in order to
get custom motion captured data
to tell a unique story so if you got a
rococo mocap suit
they're the most affordably priced ones
on the market right now slap that suit
on do a few performances until you have
data
that you really like but regardless
whether you're using miximo or a motion
capture suit
you'll just want to import it here into
cinema 4d or blender whatever you guys
are using
but it's very important that the first
frame of your mocap data
is t-posed that way we're actually able
to line up the robot or your model
with the motion capture data for a
perfect pairing this is basically the
home
base it's a way for us to easily line
things up it's gonna be a lot harder if
you have to line things up from this
random pose right here
it's finally time to bring our robot to
life we're going to take that 3d
model and we're going to parent it to
the motion capture data
so let me break down the theory behind
this for y'all basically if i
line this thing up right on top of this
mocap data
right and we get it as close as we
possibly can so that the hip joints are
basically where the hips are the knees
are basically where the knees are
the joints of the robot should basically
line up with the joints of the mocap
data the closer you can get this the
more accurate it's gonna be
all right so let me just show you guys
what this is gonna look like if i drag
the hips
into the hips of the mocap data you guys
can see how the hips
actually track with the hips from the
mocap data
so you guys are gonna need to do this
with all the different pieces of the
robot
the shoulders the arms the hands the
thighs the legs the head the neck
backpack everything until you get a
moving robot that looks and feels about
right
so the example on the right is clearly
jacked up and that's because these parts
are kind of far away from the individual
joints of the mocap data
you can see it really screws up your
model but on the left i got those as
close as i possibly could
even to the point where i scooted the
arms in a little bit and kind of broke
the model
you can scale these pieces up
individually if you want to get even
closer but it gives you guys a good idea
to see how
the closer the joints are on your model
to the joints
of the mocap data it makes for better
results
now here's a tip for you guys that
you'll want to know if your pieces get
thrown off axis or you know start
popping off in random spots
what you can do is basically select all
of your objects
come down here to the coordinates tab
and if you drop down the freeze
transformation button you can hit
freeze all and by freezing them all that
means that's their base
position scale and rotation so if some
things get thrown off
axis like this and you know your model
just starts getting all janked out on
you
what you can do is basically reset those
by selecting them
and then hitting reset psr and that'll
take it right back to
the original t-pose that you've had all
right we're basically ready to render
this robot
we have our scene set up we have
lighting that matches our footage we
have a robot that's textured with really
nice surface imperfections
we've parented it to motion capture data
and i want to go over a couple
render settings and things to watch out
for before you guys hit that render
button
now motion blur is very very important
to the realism
of your render so make sure you include
this in
octane what you want to do is give the
object you want to have motion blur in
this case the robot
and octane object tag and then in your
camera settings make sure your camera
has
a camera tag under motion blur first
make sure that's enabled and your
shutter what i do
is actually just type in the number of
my shutter speed on my camera so
if i shot this footage at 1 over 60 i
will literally type in 1 divided by 60
and that will give me the proper motion
blur for the camera now i know i shot
this
at 1 over 320 but
i want to add motion blur back into the
footage using real smart motion blur
so i'm going to meet it up in the middle
probably 1 divided by
120 or so to have a little bit of motion
blur
in there it's going to make it look nice
and it's going to be better than doing
motion blur and post
because you get the true highlight
streaks oh and make sure your shutter
alignment is set to centered you want it
to be right in the middle
so the shadow pass we want to make sure
that we render our robot and our shadow
as
separate layers that way we're able to
have the most control over it
in after effects so what i'm going to do
is on my plane that i have my shadow
catcher object on
i'm going to give that an object tag an
invisibility i'm just going to uncheck
camera visible that way i just get the
robot render
but when we come back and that's
completed you'll want to just
uncheck the visibility on your robot but
recheck visibility on your shadow plane
and you'll do a second render that way
we have both of these elements
individually rendered for the most
control in post and finally
some octane settings alright so your max
samples if you have the time
definitely set this to a higher number i
like to go 1200
plus on renders like this and your gi
clamp that's going to be set to
a million by default and you might see
some fireflies and some white spots
in your render if you're seeing that
just set it to one and another thing to
note here is the alpha channel we want
to make sure we have the alpha channel
checked
that way you know we're actually able to
composite our image on top of our
footage
and finally if we go to this far right
little clapboard icon we can get our
final render settings
definitely make sure that your width and
height is set to the same size as your
video
frame rate i usually like to keep as a
whole number and then scale it down in
after effects
29.97 if need be frame range usually set
this to all
all frames and in octane renderer we can
set up some render passes
if you're using the denoiser which is
found in the camera tab
under camera imager and spectral
denoiser if that's checked
you want to make sure that you use the
noise beauty pass by default
and then under render passes if we're
going to be doing this
you can check that find a destination
for it and just click the ones that you
find useful
i render open exr sequences that way it
kind of has a built-in redundancy if the
render fails
i'll just pick it up from the last frame
and definitely make sure you have the
alpha channel box
checked if you don't have this checked
you're gonna have to re-render with
alpha channels so definitely make sure
you've got the alpha channel thing
checked once your render gets going you
can go to the layer tab
and you can confirm here that your alpha
channel is indeed working
by going to the single pass option and
you can see yep there's my alpha
looks really nice now you all have
basically made it if you've got this far
we are on the home
stretch this is the victory lap because
we're gonna composite this in after
effects and really make it look
nice this is the satisfying part where
you get to tweak some settings
i already have the thing composited but
i'm going to go through all of my
settings and all of my layers to make
sure that you guys are getting the best
information on how to composite your
robots
into your live action footage this is
just the base footage
without any sort of color correction or
anything now on top i have a color grade
it's just a lumetri color effect
and i'm just adjusting the contrast the
highlights and shadows
and boosting the saturation a bit to
give this you know some more life to it
so let's start with our robot here okay
so we'll double click to import our
sequence whether it's an exr or png
sequence all you have to do is double
click on this file
and it's going to open up now by default
this file
if you go to interpret footage main is
set to pre-multiplied and you can see
there's a real nasty
ring around our robot you're going to
want to switch that to straight unmatted
if you want to get rid of that and also
make sure that your frame rate is
correct and matches your scene if you
guys have any tracking issues or things
are off
just double check that this matches your
footage by hitting ctrl k
and confirming that it does now on this
robot i got two things and they're
basically just here for color correction
it's a lumetri color effect and a levels
effect the lumetri color is just
adjusting a little bit of the exposure
to bring it down a bit
and the levels what i did was actually
went to this little color wheel thing
here
and i changed this to red and then with
the levels effect i go to the red
channel
i turn this on and i just adjust this a
little bit so it matches in
basically black and white mode i'm color
blind so this is a good way for me to
kind of color match stuff
and you'll just go down to the green
channel make your adjustments and sew on
to the blue channel
and that's it for just the base robot
layer just some subtle
small composites there now there's a few
other things on top what i did was
actually
rendered out a sunlight pass because i
realized there's a spot of sun against
this back
wall and things just weren't looking
right when i didn't have that in there
so you can see how much of a difference
that is making with that sunlight pass
obviously our surface imperfections are
totally paying off
they look really awesome and those
scratches underneath catch the sunlight
really nicely
i just got a basic hue saturation effect
on here to make sure that my saturation
matches
so here's a note on color matching and
brightness values
so basically if i look in my footage
right
and you know i have a lumetri color
effect on here as well
but up here in the top right you guys
will see hue saturation and brightness
hsb if i mouse over the darkest part
of my footage you can see that the
brightness is about six percent
five six percent and the saturation is
around you know seventy percent
it's a little all over the place eighty
percent but if i go to my robot
and i find the darkest point on my robot
maybe this hand here
you know saying ten percent it might be
a little
bright i need to match that so the
darkest part here was six
and the darkest part here is about ten
you know so you could bring that down
but up in here in the neck area it's
like seven nine it's not that bad
it's the same for the highlights too you
want to make sure that your highlights
the brightness is about 93 on my robot
and the brightest part of the image is
about 96
97 here so that matches up pretty nicely
and same for saturation let's take a
look at this purple color here
i'm looking at this s value right here
saturation value
it looks like it's 63 if i go up to some
of these oranges on the tree
it's around 60 to 70
which is not bad at all so that's how
i'm matching my saturation
and brightness values and finally i just
have a little reflection
pass on this robot you can see on the
edge of his helmet here there's a little
bit of something just kind of
brightening up and blending it into the
sky a little bit more now
shadows obviously we need shadows so
here's that soft shadow pass that's
rendered out and that really grounds our
robot
to the floor here and this is something
that you can come in here with a levels
effect
and go to the alpha setting and just
crank this up and down a little bit
to adjust it since we have that sunlight
pass on our robot i actually rendered
out
a hard shadow as well so if i open that
up
you can see here that the hard shadow
just kind of turns on
in this little sunspot area and i have
that
hooked up as an alpha matte to
this shadow mat basically so this shadow
mat
if i make a black solid and i make it 3d
all i'm doing here is basically hitting
w holding shift to rotate it down
flat on the ground and i'm moving it
back here and then drawing
with the elliptical mask tool a mask
around here
and i'm just saying like the area that
i'm going to select
is the area where the shadow is going to
be able to play
and that works because i have this
shadow layer beneath
this shadow matte layer and you want to
set the shadow layer to
alpha and that's going to say whatever
is inside of that black space
this shadow will be visible anywhere
outside of that black space
and it will be invisible so i can adjust
this
by hitting m and kind of working the
expansion if i want to
have the shadow kind of creep up towards
his legs a little bit more or
i can creep it back in towards the
bushes a little
bit yeah that makes a huge difference
and finally the very last thing i'm
doing is
adding a little reflection of this robot
underneath or to take off all these
effects here you can see i basically
just rendered out a mirror
that i'm using a color key effect to get
rid of the white
edge blurring it a bit and tinting it to
the color of the ground
rippling it to distort it and adjusting
the opacity
so it's very very subtle but it's in
there and it adds a little bit to the
realism there
and finally i'm just going back to the
footage here you guys can see that i'm
adding motion blur with an effect called
rsmb or real smart motion blur and that
matches it up to our robot nicely
if you guys got some sweet renders to
show me hit me up on instagram or
twitter at
underscore punisher underscore and for
the last
year i've been building a discord server
for a community of artists just like you
guys
and we do weekly challenges last week's
theme was
giant and the renders that came from
that are insane you guys are getting so
good your skills are growing so much
after consistently working the point of
this channel is to learn and grow
together
and you guys have definitely done that
and it's been a blast doing it with you
guys
now in the next couple weeks i want to
do another render montage and if you
guys missed the first one
it's basically a huge montage of renders
from other artists
who i've given a template to basically
to create a piece of art
and i combined them all together and the
work was stunning it blew me away
i gave away a bunch of cool prizes some
graphics cards and i want this
second montage to be even bigger even
better and have bigger prizes as well
so subscribe if you guys don't want to
miss that and every saturday i'm doing
live streams for you guys in cinema 4d
we're learning and we're growing our
passion together you got to do it
consistently that's the that's the key
that's the way you get better but guys
this has been a long video i'm exhausted
it's
the night before i upload it right now
and i still got a lot of work to do so
i'ma bounce guys thanks for your time
thanks for learning with me i'll catch
you guys soon peace
you